because i've gotten here by just pure
grunt work like sure oh how do you do
this well
if you go on a plane and you travel
around the world for three years and you
live out of a suitcase and you trash
every relationship you've ever had
and you just say yes to every
opportunity you'll be able to do this so
i was like yeah great done that now it's
like okay how do i get to the next level
it's like well now you need to slow down
like i i don't know what that means so
it is difficult to have the discipline
now from like a lifestyle perspective to
overcome this plateau i need to express
the discipline enough to
remove myself from that attitude of like
just keep your head down don't blink
take a bunch of drugs and then just work
until you can't work anymore then work
some more so that's that's something
that's
frankly taken more wrestling with
mentally than anything else i've ever
done because of you're telling me to not
do something
i saw something on your insta that i
really thought was interesting
have you tried trying what does that
mean
uh it means especially where i i operate
very much in an academic space
and there's a large push into
optimization
and i think a lot of times what we miss
is intentionality and we just actually
miss
the the the follow-through and the
execution and actually just
trying so a lot of people are just
becoming a repository
of useless information to just to prove
that they're smart on the internet
um but that's not why i got into this i
got into it to get stronger and
everything i've learned was just to
break a certain plateau and
really at the end of the day i think
what separates people who do things and
who do things well is
how they actually do things so people
who try when they do [ __ ]
tend to just by a consequence of trying
do [ __ ] better
that highlights something i've been
thinking about a lot which is the
bridging the gap between insight and
execution
being where almost all of the gains are
to be found
yeah because i mean you know i i work
decently close with
professional bodybuilders and you could
fill a very large room with things they
do poorly or incorrectly but the one
the one catalyst that seems to set them
apart in their sport is that they will
just
regardless of if running through walls
is the way to do it they'll do it more
and harder than anyone else so it's like
it almost creates
you know not that the the intellectual
pursuit is is a moot point but it's
if at the end of the day are you trying
to be big are you trying to be fast are
you trying to be lean or are you trying
to be smart
because you know rarely do those things
co-exist not that they can't and when
they can we can
reach something akin to optimization but
unless you have that that execution
that veracity in the way you execute
then then you're really just collecting
you know iq points for no i'd rather i'd
rather add two inches to my arm than 10
points to my iq
that's spoken like a true powerlifter uh
yeah we have a buddy who's often on the
show
youssef and he speaks about a period
while he was a med student where he said
he
uselessly indexed information for the
ruthless hell of it
and i think that mental masturbation and
the sort of cerebral game that a lot of
people can play um
it does lead to an action certainly 2020
it's been the year of people ruminating
right
uh yeah it can [ __ ] you too right
like you can
it you know the if the
negative effects of your own intellect
like falling in love with your own
creation
right i think is a lot of times leaving
people to just be this and this giant
one dimensional intellect and you know
if
i don't know how deep into that the
religious or
philosophical psychosocial rabbit hole
you want to go but like that was
one of the the the breakdowns of
religion in western society that was
what kind of led
to the proclamation of god being dead
was the fact that it fell in love with
its own creation right and i feel a lot
of people i'll be maybe not as profound
a result of that
but you know lead them to that sort of
crippling inaction because they do fall
in love with their own
creation with you know the more they
know it's it's just like
that's not why i got into this i wonder
whether that's a
byproduct of the convenience of the 21st
century
like no one's making [ __ ] with their
hands anymore like you know when i need
a room in my house
decorating a ring a decorator i don't go
and do it myself because i can find a
deliveroo of michelin star meal while
you're watching
netflix documentary and amazon prime the
tv to your house you know like this
hyper convenience i wonder whether
that's forcing people to not put skin in
the game
with things that they previously might
have done yeah
i just think there's there's a new
landscape in which we're competing on
now right like
the plumbers i never picked a plumber
based off of instagram
right but people are picking coaches and
people are picking
educators and people are picking you
know anything to do in the
supplements or products or whatever in
the fitness space
based off of you know the trading and
social capital
right so i really think that there is
like you kind of said a removal of that
skin
in the game and you don't necessarily
have to be competitive at the execution
you just have to be competitive in this
in this simulation right so you you
check the boxes that
so you write a smart post and you get
feedback positive reinforcement like oh
i picked up three new clients
because i used a bunch of big words but
it's like okay are you trying to acquire
clients are you trying to retain clients
if you can't actually you know follow
through on that you can't execute and
you don't know whether or not your
principles actually work
then it's like you're constantly going
to be in from a business standpoint in
this phase of acquisition
where that just leads you down creating
loudness rabbit hole of creating this
repository and i love the word ruthless
like that repository that ruthless
pursuit
of creating this repository of like
useless information
right so it's just yeah i think social
media is large in part to do with that
accumulation that hoarding
of information it's like a you know i
know something you don't know
essentially it creates like a flat
earthers of fitness that's just like
everyone's trying to come up with their
own shtick
just to be different right it's it's
just to prove that they can survive and
that and if you want to survive you got
to train with me sort of thing so it's
uh
yeah it's an interesting it's a very
interesting business
in the fitness uh exclusive i don't
think real estate
succumbs to that same issue i don't know
if high finance like i don't know if uh
i don't know how many followers uh
you know warren buffett has on instagram
but i guarantee you there's some fitness
check out there with a promo code that
has more
how do you compete then in this
marketplace what were
the complaint that we have here is that
people win at this game who
don't have the virtue to win that
they're all show and no grow
that the results don't actually speak
for themselves it's just that they're
fantastic marketers
but if you're a guy out there who is an
unbelievable pt or a fantastic plumber
or whatever it is truly you still need
to play the game you gotta
do the instagram thing use the hashtags
put the good content up with that lovely
depth of field effect in the background
look at us go
uh yeah yeah i think it's um the nice
part about the game is you get to define
what winning is
so you get to define your lines in the
sand right
it's not predetermined for you there are
things that work in various
uh various speeds i would say like yeah
if i wanted to sell my soul to the devil
i would know exactly how i would do
it right there would be you know some
sort of diet that would shred me down to
six percent
there'd be a bunch of pictures taken
with me without my shirt on
and then the whole depth of field thing
and all that but you know i don't
following is i think how people think
the game is one
right like building followings or
subscribers or downloads or whatever but
to me that's you know it's a business
like it's one in law
it's the one and lost to the bottom line
so i know people who have
smaller followings that convert well
that sell great products and retain
great
but they don't have a swipe up on their
instagram account but
the way i measure winning in dollars and
cents is like they got some digits in
the bank account that
they've won right so i think it's it is
understanding that look if you are
trying to utilize social media
from a business gain understand what
winning in business really means
right because it's not the be-all
end-all metric and
in the indicator to which you are going
to earn
money right so i think a lot of people
get caught chasing the wrong things and
then if they do acquire
a massive following by you know whatever
means necessary
they're in a position where likely
they're not they're not um
they're not really apt to monetize and
then they're left scrambling to try and
build systems it's like
if you can a following will come if you
put out value
and you will be able to work more
efficiently if your
success if you define winning by sort of
that bottom line
um so it's something that you know you
get a little serotonin dump every now
and then you get a new follow or a like
or whatever
but you know if you can start to get
those serotonin dumps when you get
deposits into your bank account i think
that should be more of your focus and if
you geared your decisions
more off of that and obviously like you
have to have a moral
guideline in which like you don't cross
certain lines
but i think if that's you know being a
consumer or creator if you're on the
creative side of social media
i think starting from a business
standpoint will actually allow you to
define those ethical and moral lines a
little um
a little bit more clearly because you
won't have to make desperate moves based
purely off of just acquiring that bottom
line
i think people see through it as well
you can we all know that person on
instagram who
will do anything for another video to
bang
and even if they're winning at the game
of instagram
they're being laughed at by all of the
people who might even watch the video
there's like a i'm sure you'll have them
as well i i've done
quite efficiently this year at removing
the slow motion car crash
accounts from my account that i was
obsessed with watching
because there's something so compelling
about watching someone
just wade through hypocrisy day after
day after day
but you don't know if the success that
that person has
is because everybody else is doing the
same thing i can't believe that this
person is just living
such a like vapid
like completely shallow life um but from
the outside it might look like they're
winning
i think the real concern there is not
only at a certain point do
you know other people in the industry
start to see through it and to a certain
degree that'll bleed into
the general the general public or the
consumer but my biggest concern and
being around this for
however many years i've been around this
for is when you start to see through it
where you as a perpetrator of this
dissonant character on the internet
versus real life
i've seen people literally lose their
minds like hospitalized
anxiety attacks panic attacks because
they're they're dissonant characters
right there is the simulation online
there is the avatar of themself
and then there's the person on on like
to which that exists on the other
22 hours a day where they're not on
their phone or 20
or 20 or 18 or 16 or two hours or not on
their phone depending on who it is and
it's like that's the biggest concern to
me it's like yeah
it's one thing for other people to see
through it but it'll always get to a
point where
doing it for the gram is your life and
livelihood
and if there's a dissonance between who
you are on the internet and who you are
in real life
the more that wedge begins to divide the
more trouble you're actually going to be
in so that for me like i was lucky
enough in a certain sense to be exposed
to people who have lived that dissonance
and lived as a as a word i use kind of
loosely in that case because it really
was
kind of driving a wedge through their
psyche because they do
have these dual personalities like
people who may be a little bit more
introverted in the way they would
operate in the day-to-day
that the second the story was on they
were like yeah they swipe uh
then the next thing you know they go
reclusive and it's every time they go
reclusive they feel the need to go
more extravagant when the record button
is on and that
spirals them back to this refractory
further inclusivity and then all of a
sudden they're just
you know this schizophrenic bipolar
person's multiple
split personality disorder and it's
social media is i think
large to blame the the how we reward
people who do have these car crash
accounts with
keeping them on the needle of the likes
and the follows and the subscribes and
the shares
that only rewards that behavior and
further creates the distance between the
avatar that exists on the internet and
the person that exists in real life
until some point that then just breaks
how do you avoid tumbling into that hole
yourself never post
anything that isn't true in real life
what does that mean um if ever like
don't do anything just for instagram
like don't everything from like i'm not
gonna go off program to hit a pr on a
lift for instagram
because that's how it starts right like
whether that's friendships whether
that's relationships i know couples that
only post
as a means of saying sorry for some sort
of argument that's existing in real life
i know a buddy of mine i'm not going to
name his name but every time you post a
picture of him and his girl
i know he's sleeping on the [ __ ]
couch 100
1000 like i know like that
is the relationship exists on social
media and i know every time that card
gets played it's like oh [ __ ]
like i'm not going to name names but
buddy buddy supposed to picture him and
his girl everyone's like oh it's
adorable it's like oh man i got it with
a bridge you need a place to
use a place to stay tonight so it's like
whatever the situation is it just has to
be it has to be a transparency
and i'm not saying like go on there you
know and this is one thing i can't stand
like
you know don't we all got problems right
they don't use like talking about
psychological problems on social media
is like talking about your drinking
problem at the bar
it's like you're kind of missed to the
point here this is the exact reason so
it's like
there has to be a certain level of
transparency but also a certain level of
privacy there needs to be things you do
for yourself that aren't on social media
that and but there are lines that you
draw that okay now this is where my
private life
ends it's still a continuation of me and
this is what i can put on the internet
right so i think there there has to be
kind of a two-way street of like okay
i don't want to create dissonance by
doing things specifically for the
internet but i also don't want to have
the internet be
a full-on voyeuristic view of me as an
entire person
that makes sense i i push back a little
bit i think about the
the psychological issues if you're doing
it for the reason that i know that this
is going to get sympathy likes
then yeah certainly not on the flip side
of that i do think that it's important
for people who are in positions
that have large followings to show
that they're not as bulletproof as their
instagram
may lead people to believe it is by its
very essence a highlight reel of
everybody's lives
and i think yeah you can weaponize polar
opposite of that
and use it for a nefarious reason which
is i know if i post me
with a tear running down my face or a
really long caption that talks about how
i was suicidal last night
like that that may be too far but
certainly reflectively
talking about having a bad year coming
up against issues
like that nuance i think is really
really important it's something that i
enjoy doing myself and it's a
competitive advantage because i'm
prepared
to look at the ugly bits of my life and
then
talk about them mostly on the show
rather than an instagram caption but i
do think it's important
and that's and that's a caveat right
like i think talk about them
the medium is the message right like
i'll go i mean i have an hour-long
podcast that like
jeez i and it is because it is a
conversation
like from ex-wife's to ex-girlfriends
like i've gone on my friend's podcast
like my podcast is whatever like i have
friends who have podcasts and
hundreds of thousands and millions of
downloads a year
and like i've discussed because they're
all my friends it's on the internet
whatever
so i i definitely agree like agree to a
certain extent that
you know there there is that that
unfiltered unpolished look
we all got problems i you know i am
someone who's on the other side or
creator on instagram or whatever
but i don't think instagram is the place
because instagram is not a place for
dialogue and conversation
right so like i've i've gone candid and
talked about things
and i've received text messages on the
back but it's things that i would say
to anyone's face but on podcasts and
that's what i like
podcasts you know creating this this
repository of conversation because
there is it is dialogue because we
couldn't you know how many posts we
would have to
have to go back and forth on this
conversation
right i'd tag you like oh i don't i
don't think people should talk about
whatever like well i was talking about
podcasts right so i think exactly
you know that would be a great youtube
series we just go back and forth at each
other
and just have some youtube i've struck
i've seen some really good stuff from
uh rationality rules guy called stephen
woodford over here he's a youtuber
philosophy youtuber
and him and a christian philosopher
went back and forth about a particular
argument for the existence of god
and they did like a debate would be but
they uploaded
the opening statement from one then the
opening statement from the other then
the first rebuttal then the second
rebuttal
and they just made it into a little
series and it was on each other's
channel and it actually ended up being i
mean
like philosophy of religion's not
something that i would spend all day
watching but the concept i thought was
was relatively interesting
yeah but see there's to me it's if we're
especially in a debate setting
it has to be instantaneous right because
i don't wanna i wanna
i i can't like my hands are up here
everything i'm talking about i'm pulling
from my own
like my own working memory yeah so it's
an interesting platform but it's like
to me this there's nothing realer than
this
there's nothing we've evolved more like
more in sync with
than this interaction so any latency
creates a level of dis uh
disingenuousness or or
a lack of congruency like a lack of
truth to it so for me like you got to be
able to bring it in this setting you got
to be able to like go mono and model and
have this conversation like well i
disagree well okay well instagram versus
social or
instagram versus podcast great sorted
right where it's like it's the same i
suppose is
sparring in the cage or throwing
combinations on the bag next to each
other
exactly yeah and i've never once paid
for a pay-per-view of someone just
hitting the speed bag
that's a good point yeah man uh one
thing i was thinking earlier on
there's this example i think it's uh
analog to the malthusian trap
which is where you get population
overgrowth and it was me thinking about
people that perhaps play the game on
social media to an extreme
being uh out competing those who don't
and that's a what have you done have you
dropped something i'm looking for the
charger for my computer but do continue
all these chords technological numbers
today uh yeah so
um you can imagine this experiment
where you've got a ton of rats living on
an island let's say there's a thousand
of them
over time these rats develop culture and
politics and art and dance and all of
this beautiful stuff music
and what the rats find out is that
as the population approaches uh
pretty much the um top-end capacity it
starts to
level out because there's less and less
resources you could see this as
higher competition within a market for
clients or for likes or for content or
for eyes
as it approaches that some of the rats
actually realize hang on
if i don't do that dance and art and
music [ __ ] i can spend more time
foraging for food and trying to
reproduce
so the rats who do do the stuff the more
virtuous stuff
the adds flavor and content to the world
actually get out competed by the ones
who just go for the lowest common
denominator
and what you see over time is that all
of the rats that do music
and politics and art and all that stuff
they all get out competed
until the entire system drops down
to a more shallow state
and that's i think what we're perhaps
seeing with social media
that you have people who are able to
compete by playing the game
and the out competing of the people who
are potentially doing something more
virtuous because it doesn't resonate so
much on the channel
actually leads to an evolution of less
and less of that content
yeah i think there's two ways to look at
it right like because in the
in that rat model we're looking at a
very
definitive finite resource where i think
in
there's this i i see that in operation i
see that in action in the social media
sphere based around like
you know more in the fitness space but i
think
that's a closed-minded view to look
because i don't think we're tapping into
finite resources
it's not a zero-sum game on social media
but people treat it like it is
yeah yeah and i think and that's the
biggest thing is realizing that look
like
you know in our industry we touch a very
small part of the
overall real world we're so disconnected
with that real world that we don't
realize how many people don't give a
[ __ ]
about the little like crap i could you
know
i'll go go to places with people that in
the bodybuilding community have millions
of
followers and you take them to a grocery
store and don't give a [ __ ]
and then you realize there's way more
people that don't give a [ __ ] than
people that give a [ __ ] so it's like
yeah that that zero sump game it's like
you know it can be a positive sum game
in the sense that
you know those creatives shouldn't feel
the pressure of dealing in a in an
ecosystem of finite resources because
there are so many
resources right so i think there's a
certain level of attrition
and there's a certain level of patience
for those creatives to be
you know just that they require of them
to stick to their guns to
create an audience and i think coming
back to our earlier conversation like i
think if
they saw the business sense first they
could survive without going down
and sort of selling out and and just
becoming these very
industrious play the game sort of things
i think people resort to that because
at the end of the day the bottom line is
is infringed upon and that's going to
lead them
to create these decisions out of
desperation
in the middle of winter at the moment
moving on to your proper proper
wheelhouse which is
stopping people from getting injured or
fixing them if they are injured
what would you prescribe to someone this
year
who you think is looking to avoid
injuries for 2021
what are the biggest mistakes that you
see people making that cause injuries to
occur
a lot of them a lot of the mistakes are
i think are being based off of
just reintroduction to training coming
out of locked downs
so in cases where people have gone from
you know the ever illustrious home
workout
to uh you know back into a gym setting
there's a certain level like
of understanding that we have around
training almost intuitively when it
comes to
overloading like if i went for an off
program
pr or something of the like and succumb
to an injury
like a lot of people would look at that
be like well got no [ __ ] right obviously
you did
but people don't see severely under
loading their exercise
as something that could potentially lead
to injury so i think one of the best
things you could do
is create a proper program in
reintroducing yourself into exercise
so i think just with the state of the
world and i know the uk
the fluctuations of lockdowns and no
more lockdowns and
and all of that stuff and very similar
here in canada i think there's a certain
eagerness to like really jump back into
the fire
um once the gyms are open and there's a
certain like you know
um like making up for lost time that
kind of overwhelms people's
people's decision-making but i think
having a plan and sticking with that
plan knowing that that time off has not
it's not the major deload that you
needed you haven't been training that
hard your whole life that you needed
three months off the gym and you're just
gonna super compensate and just be like
it's like no you're likely in a state of
you know phys i don't want to say
fragility because i think that's that's
overstepping but
there should be a certain level of
trepidation around
how it is you reintroduce programming
into um
into your exercise and getting back into
the gym for 2021 right there's because
there's this height and hopefully we're
all in places that are
starting to open back up again um and
you know paired with that the usual
enthusiasm around exercise that comes
with the new year resolutions and all
that but i would i would put pen to
paper
and i would be i don't want to say
conservative but cognizant when it comes
to your exercise programming
coming into the new year i've always
said the number one piece of advice to
anybody pivoting from
bro split bodybuilding into crossfit
which was what i did
was to never go above an 8 out of 10 for
the first three months
in terms of effort and it was just that
top to
20 was where all of the injuries could
occur
that was where you were going to slip a
disc that was where you were going to
overextend your elbow or that was where
you were going to [ __ ] give yourself
rhabdo because you thought it was fun
and um that dialing it back makes a lot
of sense
what else are there some movement
patterns that you think people need to
be particularly aware of
some common uh common sort of lineages
that you see
when people get back into training yeah
i mean i always
like there's there's two depths of
resolution that i
usually look at the body yeah depending
on who i'm looking at we kind of we can
utilize one or two of these systems and
oftentimes they kind of superimpose but
i look at for most people most of the
time we look at shoulder hip and spine
right like and my biggest thing is you
know what is our access to full range of
motion
uh so mobility being more an active
pursuit rather than flexibility being
passive
and are we loading within those
limitations right like if i can't put my
arm over my head without weights in my
hands
probably shouldn't have my arm over my
head with weights in my hands i think
that's a pretty sound principle and same
thing with like
you know if i can't squat ass to grass
with no weight on my back
probably shouldn't be getting there by
means of a barbell and a bunch of plates
and then the spline is a little bit
different like can i resist force in all
three planes so
i kind of look at range of motion first
most primarily in the shoulder because
we have the greatest potential for range
of motion at the shoulder
right like i can't walk in like a gold
member and [ __ ] put my right foot
next to my ear right my hips just not
that mobile
right so with the shoulder i'm really
focused on range of motion and then
stability at the end range of motion
then loading strength
with the hips range of motion could be a
limiting factor but oftentimes we just
want to get right into stability
can we can we can you do a walking lunge
if you can't like when we walk around
all day
and like if we look at like our gait
cycle so our gait cycle is broken down
into phases one of the phases is called
stance phase
stance phase is the point in which when
we're walking that we're on one leg
right and walking is you know our other
than breathing as our
most evolved adaptation that we sort of
learn to do right you can't
walk very well you know you're probably
not going to be able to
pass on your genes historically right
that's not the case in in
in today's world but there was a time
where that was the case
so if we look at if we look at walking
for the hips it's like all right
can you do like a walking lunge if you
can't spend some time in exaggerated
phases of gait cycle it's like well
maybe a barbell back squat's
probably not in your future right so
picking out like exercises that i like
to call like i've coined like gatekeeper
drills
so there's a handful of exercises that i
think are like mobility and stability
prerequisites to loading strength
it shows proof of concept that you have
the adequate range of motion
to get into these certain positions and
have the stability or the ability to
resist
force at the end of these ranges of
motion which are structured
limits our ability to stabilize our
joints and then give calls upon our
muscles to do so
so i mean i'm always i'm a huge advocate
of any gait cycle movement
right so you know start with something
like a walking lunge start with
something like a single leg rdl start
with something like a bulgarian splits
water a rear foot elevated split squat
or some sort of
some sort of derivation of front foot or
rear foot elevated something that
looks like how our hips function as we
sort of
walk around and then the upper body hits
you know try and improve your range of
motion so you can get you know
without getting too technical i want to
see full flexion external rotation the
glenohumeral joint with the neutral rib
cage
and in the lower body i want to be able
to see these unilateral
gait cycle patterns get us into a
position of extension and internal
rotation of the hip with a neutral
pelvis
and then at the core what would you what
would the exercise be for overhead or
for shoulder uh so i like
so it depends on where you're at in a
very remedial sense and testing
stability through the overhead a
kettlebell bottom under press i think is
one of my
favorite because a lot of times we look
at the rotator cuff and we think about
you know
creating this mass amount of rotation
against resistance
but we're never really doing that when
we're training right i'm not coming in
and
doing a dumbbell press and flapping my
wings the rotator cuff kind of acts like
like like uh like the tracks on a smith
machine
um the more output we can have he'll
allow
your prime movers i don't necessarily
like the word but let's just call it
prime movers for now
to exert force right so if we don't have
that stability
we're not going to be able to really
challenge our muscles to their their
potential
so something like a kettlebell bottom
one right down the line it kind of comes
into like
if i'm doing pull-ups if i'm doing dips
these are really good
integrated rotator cuff exercises that
train our shoulder through full flexion
and full extension
and even into hyper extension with the
dips but in early stages if we have
someone who might have compromised
shoulders
that might be a good place to start just
with a kettlebell bottom under press
just because it's it's very attenuated
load you don't need to default to
someone's body weight
and it just is going to highlight any
limitations in range of motion at the
shoulder like if you don't have that
ability to stay flexed and externally
rotated
in the shoulder with a neutral ribcage
and you start to internally rotate that
kettlebell is going to fall right
through your hand
right so those are exercises so lower
body again just a recap
start with gait cycle movement
stationary lunge walking lunge
single leg rdl hip airplane really try
and you know elicit a stimulus of
instability through the lower body
can you minimize your basis support and
deviate your center of mass
in a way that yours the muscles of
stability around these joints of the
shoulder and the hip
have to now resist force so if you have
proof of concept that these muscles can
resist force
you've licensed your ability to then
strengthen and exert force
right so range of motion mobility or
variability however you want to look at
it
stability or capacity do you have the
capacity to hold these positions and
then that'll
license you the ability to then exert
strength or power so mobility stability
strength
variability capacity power those are
kind of like a
it's like it's a timing issue it's it's
an order of operations if you will
of how it is you can tear movements in a
way that
complement the acquisition of skill of
the next progression of movement
and then the spine yeah so the spine
more specifically the lumbar spine so
the lumbar spine is where we seem to
have the greatest amount of issues
because we have the
least amount of structural stability
right so the lumbar spine
you want is basically defined by uh you
know the the five vertebra
beneath the thoracic spine the thoracic
spine has this you know the unique
uh structure of the rib cage that gives
it a lot of stability
that's why we don't see well there's a
lot of reasons why we don't see thoracic
spine disc herniations
as often but one of the major reasons is
we have this i think of like stepping on
a pop can right like if i stepped on a
pop can it was fully sealed
i would have you know circumferential
distribution of force that would allow
me at whatever 120 kilos to stand on a
sealed
pop can and it not break right but the
second there's a dent in that pop can
then it flattens right so if i'm looking
at if i'm looking at the whole
torso from like let's say the neck down
to the the tailbone or the sacrum or the
pelvis
and i'm seeing you know a lumbar spine
it doesn't have that structural
stability and we don't have an ability
to resist force internally using some of
whether it's the you know the core for
internal obliques external obliques
transverse abdominus rectus abdominus
whether it's the lats whether it's the
glutes or more internally
whether it's the you know multifidus or
the rotatory or the erectors deeper
spinal muscles if we don't have
that lumbar spine segment as
stable internally with our muscles as a
thoracic spine segment is stabilized
externally let's say with our ribs
then that's the dent in the pop can
right that's the dents of the popcorn
that if i'm going to apply a load to
that that's where things are going to
converge
right that's where those forces are
going to converge and it potentially
causes some issues
so being able to resist force through
all three planes with the core so if i
think about
you know really common practice is is
the mcgill big
three right so the side plank to curl up
in the bird dog
now this is a good starting point for
someone who is d
trained someone who has a young training
age little experience in the gym little
experience with athletics
um but it's not the be all end all right
like for a guy like you guy like me
you know a bird dog compared to a 300
kilo deadlift a bird dog should not give
you
licensing like you know moral or
or physical licensing to be able to
deadlift 300 kilos
right like what am i proving that my
spine can resist force when i'm crawling
around on all fours
and i'm trying to transfer that
application to when i'm
standing upright with you know a ton of
weight in my hands
so the idea i think is sound the core
essence of that big three model is sound
because if we think about these
exercises
side plank is an anti-lateral flexion
right or you could look at that as like
an x-axis through our body
uh bird dog is it's a few things but i
think at its essence compared to the
other ones it's an anti-rotation drill
right opposite shoulder opposite hip and
then if we look at the curl up it's sort
of this anti-flexion extension right so
we kind of have resistance of force
through all three planes the problem is
those need to scale right so how is it
that we can use these principles of
instability deviation of center of mass
or limitation of base support and apply
them across these three exercises to
scale
the intent and therefore the adaptation
that we're going to derive from these
exercises right so
think of like the let's go with the curl
up so
a curl up would maybe go to a plank from
the knees
to plank at the feet to maybe like an ab
wheel or reverse ghr setup or a body saw
right and all the way up to a certain
degree to you know a romanian deadlift
where now we're trying to resist force
through flexion extension of our spine
right and then from a bird dog
perspective it's like a anti-rotation
i would probably start if i was starting
with someone from ground zero i'd
probably start with something like a
dead bug
dead bug is gonna be a much more
remedial anti-rotation drill because
your spine's supported by the floor so i
would go dead bug
bird dog maybe some sort of bear crawl
maybe some sort of uh supported single
leg rdl
and then start to scale that all the way
up to like maybe a single arm dumbbell
row
right now that can create a massive
runway of progression through
anti-rotation of the trunk
um and then finally lateral flexion
right like side plank side plank from
the knees and then maybe copenhagen
plank
and then unilateral carries or something
like that so through the spine it's
about
being able to identify core work
specific to the adaptation we're
attempting to yield
and making sure we're not redundant in
planes of motion that we're resisting
force through
right so a lot of people will just do
core arbitrarily and they end up
they end up having some holes right they
do maybe two or three exercises for
anti-flex and extension
and then maybe nothing for anti-rotation
and then when they incorporate you know
maybe back squats or deadlifts their
body is going to default through the
path of least resistance that they've
set forth by the muscles that have been
trained
adequately to support their trunk and
they're always going to
sort of have this weak link consequence
of like look if you haven't trained
anti-rotation when you're loading that
core
axially with a deadlift or a squat your
body is going to find that path of least
resistance and the ex
is now going to be exposed to the
isolated instability through that
particular range that we didn't pay
attention to
so when we look at the core it's really
easy to index whether or not our core
work is anti-lateral reflection
anti-rotation or anti-flexion extension
and not that any of these exercises are
going to be mutually exclusive to these
categories rather suggesting
small biases towards each particular
plane of movement which we're attempting
to resist
so on the flip side of it what we're
trying to do is making sure that
once we index these exercises making
sure and kind of this plate
spinning approach we're keeping all the
balls in the air we're keeping all the
plates spinning
right so if i have someone who's really
struggling with a bird dog
but they're rocking copenhagen planks
and they're rocking
you know uh reverse ghr setups they've
shown
a great capacity a great stability
through
anti-flexion extension or anti-lateral
flexion
yet this bird dog is still stifling them
i'm worried about
how it is their body's going to organize
their rib cage and pelvis
when we put them through an axial load
because their deficiency is going to be
in their ability to resist force through
rotation
so i want to make sure i'm constantly
keeping an eye on you know where are we
at this index are we
making sure are we trading at the same
level of complexity the same level of
instability across all three layers of
trunk and how can i progress this
further and further and further
that's really kind of the goal is you
wanna at a certain point you want to
make corrective exercise
merely the pursuit of exercising
correctly right so i don't you know we
see these things in isolation
you know i've the bird dog is a deadlift
warm ups like look if you needed bird
dog before you deadlift you either
shouldn't be doing a burdog or shouldn't
be deadlifting i think it's quite simple
right like if you're at the point where
you're loading a barbell in front of
your body which is
relatively inefficient from a center of
mass and
base support standpoint you better make
sure the bugs are barking
right and if you really need to wake up
the muscles required to stabilize your
spine
with a remedial body weight quadruped
offset shoulder flexion hip extension
probably shouldn't be on the barbell
neck and if you are confident on the
barbell you're probably wasting your
[ __ ] time
doing little bird dogs before you
deadlift
so the core does become i don't want to
say a bit of a rabbit hole
but everything converges at that that
center piece of our body
so stability at the spine is in a large
way
a linchpin to most people's progression
whether it's peripheral at the shoulder
or the hip or whether it's even local to
like
compound movements that's usually where
we see the breakdown and the breakdown
is going to happen
at the link that we're not paying
attention to so being able to index this
way anti-rotation anti-lateral flexion
anti-flexion extension
and being able to make sure we're
constantly progressing using exercise
selection
right and i feel so many times we
progress arbitrarily through
you know distance or we progress
arbitrarily through load being the most
common one right trying to build more
strength
it's like you know i could do let's say
like a superman or
so i don't know why you would yeah
people still do and i could put
someone's
a plate on someone's back and be like
now it's a weighted superman it's like
couldn't we just come up with another
exercise
like maybe we could put up where load
would matter you know what be a good
like
spinal extension exercise under load a
good morning
a good morning is an exercise we could
add weight to and that expression of
strength and
adding resistance to that movement is
going to be beneficial
right where people get stuck in the in
the exercise rather than
they rather than marrying themselves to
the intent of the exercise
like look you're trying to improve
whatever global extension or
rectors or whatever it's like yeah okay
if we can
check off the box of the superman drill
we have licensed our ability physically
license our ability to move on to a more
complex way to organize
spinal extension or anti-flexion of the
thoracic spine
so then using exercise progression as
the most expedient means in which to
create adaptation i think is something
that's widely overlooked bulletproofing
the body
through those areas i think would if you
if you could avoid
injuries in the shoulder hip and spine
what percent of injuries that you come
up against do you reckon that would
remove
um it's tough right because people it
depends on the population you're going
to work with as a heuristic for most
people most of the time
i would say upwards of 80 90 and i use
those numbers because
there are 10 percent of people in my
experience that are going to bend it
until it breaks
they're the people who are not in their
exercising muscles that they're in there
exercising demons and those people
then that's why i sort of talked about
two models one of a higher resolution
that's where the
the biomechanical model i to me gets a
little bit more in depth
uh and that's when we start to encompass
biomechanics around
the ribcage and the pelvis so if you
you're dealing with gen pop weekend
warriors essentially if
if someone's not paying their way and
putting food on their table with
exercise to a certain
level like if they're not if there's not
money in a bank account for them
exercising or as you know as sport
endeavor on the back end of exercising
shoulder hip and spine
is a very expedient heuristic
in which to look at human movement for
the general population
that ability to index and scale based
off of intent
movements of stability at the root from
you know bottom under press to dip
most people wouldn't see a correlation
between bottom under press and dip
because they don't understand the
function of the rotator cuff
you know from stationary lunge to single
leg rdl
to be stance rdl like most people
wouldn't link those exercises
together necessarily but if you
understand the intent of them you would
right from bear crawl to
you know farmers carry some people might
not categorize them together
but if you have someone who's you know
making seven figures a year
then we might go a resolution higher and
look at rib cage and pelvis but if
you're
you know if your athletes aren't on espn
every night that shoulder hip and spine
model is a really good heuristic that
allows us to see the body in a in a
requisite resolution
that will more than exceed the demands
of the clock
the tasks your clients need to perform
and would you say that
looking after those areas with some of
or variants of the exercises that you've
given there
is that the foundation upon which
everything else is built or are there
some other
parts to the bulletproof your body for
2021 story that we need to add
i mean a lot of it comes down to
assessment so you can make better
choices of where the starting points are
right because some people their their
rotator cuff intervention is going to be
dips right away
right some people it's going to be you
know some sort of range of motion drill
like if you don't have the mobility a
kettlebell bottom under press is going
to be useless right
so it's it's assessing i think that's
what a lot of systems miss
is about creating effective exclusion
criteria to implement expedient
programming for which then you can coach
from
right because if i just start everyone
off and i have a system
well here's my system everyone has to
bird dogs i think well [ __ ] man i've
been a chiropractor personal trainer
strength conditioning coach for 15 years
[ __ ] i need a bird dog for like you need
to filter out a way that i like
oh [ __ ] okay you don't need a burdock
you need to do a single arm dumbbell row
with 100 kilos
that's your that's you know your
anti-rotation through your trunk this is
how you set it up
to create rotation so i think to start
off there'd be two things that
encapsulate maybe that shoulder hip and
spine model
one on the front end would be a good
intake form that allows you to write
effective programming and on the back
end is the effective programming
right so these exercises are really kind
of real-time data to give us information
as to what our capacity is to resist
force
in these unstable positions but
preceding that should be a filtration
process that
allows us to pick on this scale of
exercises what adaptation we think this
client can actually uh operate at what
level of intent this client can actually
operate out to make an adaptation
like i don't want to take someone who's
70 and have them do single arm
dumbbell rows out of the gate right
maybe i start that person off with a
bird dog
that's their anti-robot and i can only
extrapolate their baseline from
some sort of assessment right whether
it's a
written written history or some sort of
dialogue i've had with the client
so on the front end of like really
making a full
like a full working model out of this
you would want to create a detailed
movement
history and then you on the back end of
that is you would want to create an
expedient exercise program
right so then the idea of bulletproofing
again not my favorite
word because i'm sure you know as as
good of a bottom under presser as i am
you know a good glock 17 would really do
my shoulder in
so but i think you know you can't out
corrective exercise bad exercise
right so at a certain degree we need to
pay equal attention to the exercises we
are performing sure
but how we're performing these exercises
when we're performing these exercises so
no peace is more important than the
other but i think a lot of times we
overlook
this this stability piece we look we
overlook this
this physical prerequisite model to like
physically license our ability
to perform these these more advanced
exercises
so i would say you know create a good
detailed assessment whether it's a
physical assessment whether it's a
historical assessment i would i would
argue for both being important
go through then you know your ability to
express
capacity or stability in these end
ranges of shoulder hip and spine
and then go from there into programming
and proper execution
what about if someone doesn't have
access to a chiropractor and they've
just got to self-regulate with this
stuff
yeah great i mean probably better off
that way honestly the way most
chiropractors work if i'm being like
i can i can talk [ __ ] because i am one
um
and i know this the standard is not
great um yeah
it's you know everything is on the
internet and it's to what degree it's
expedient for you we're cost effective
for you to go and find it
because there are you know obviously
there's
there's tangible subdivisions of that
heuristic that you look at the shoulder
through a particular lens you look at
the hip through a particular lens
there's a way to create
your own internal system of checks and
balances
it's just a matter of how much you want
to put into it and that's why most
people go pay a chiropractor
because they're hoping hoping being the
operative word
that on the other end of it they're
going to have a uh
you know some sort of home exercise some
sort of
action plan that's often not the case
and if it is it's usually little stick
figure drawings of remedial exercises
that
they've printed off since grad school
and they've been photocopying a hundred
times
a month and until you get your hands on
one so it is difficult to kind of sift
through
the noise to find signal but it's it's
definitely out there but i would say the
biggest thing is just to start
right and if you can control your
variables you can start to accurately
accept
for the validity of your implementation
right if you change everything it's like
well this whole equation's upside down
now so i don't know one of these things
is actually giving me a positive return
so just being very methodical being very
um
reproducible like okay i'm going to do
this for my shoulder warm up and see
what it does i'm going to do this for my
hip warm up or workout and see what it
does
and then that'll allow you over time to
distill down to something that is very
effective
so you know intuitive athletes do this
all like do this really well
and when you look at it from a
scientific perspective or a
biomechanical perspective like wow
this guy doesn't know the difference
between a serratus anterior and a knee
but in what he does to prepare is very
congruent with you know biomechanics and
he's he's organizing his body in a way
to activate these muscles or
or to deactivate other muscles or what
have you um
but if you don't have that that uh
intuition
it can be learned right it's just a
matter of you know what is it worth to
you to spend the time to learn it
looking forward to 2021 what are you
going to be working on
personally have you got some areas that
you're looking to develop or restrict
within yourself over the next year
like are you talking my own personal
training or just a from a business
perspective
from a business and mindset perspective
more so yeah
um really working on like
optimization around my schedule so kind
of working with someone right now to
try and get the most out of me from a
day to day week to week month to month
you know i'm very much i keep your head
down and go until you can't and if you
run into a wall just run through it
and that has got me pretty far but it's
not really a sustainable or efficient
model
so definitely looking at a few scheduled
work deloads to stay topical to the
conversation
um and then on the business front it got
just so
yeah a lot of curriculum development a
lot of writing uh
i started a handful of other businesses
that are in various stages of like
pre-production or programming or things
like that so i have
uh one two three companies now that i'm
in uh have sort of taken some level of
ownership of
so a lot of next year is gonna be kind
of moving into unchartered territories
on the business end
everything from some technology stuff
some administrative stuff some advising
stuff
and then sticking with creating
curriculum and developing a handful of
new courses for
for prescript so 2021 is pretty much
already done in my opinion
uh so looking forward now into 2022 uh
yeah it'll be it should be a busy year
and hopefully with any luck be able to
get to your side of the pond
as soon as possible yeah man well i'd
wait until it warms up a little bit
because it's
absolutely freezing at the moment you
had a post on your
instagram that i think relates to what
you were just talking about you said if
you love
something let it kill you and i think
this this
talks about the
feet first approach to out-competing
people
first through workload but also that
embracing your passion fully
and taking an essentialist perspective
actually allows us to
really sort of feel the nuances of
everything we do it also gives you a
competitive advantage and other things
but as you've just identified there it's
not sustainable
so how do you balance those two things
strategically um i think that's
something that
if if you know like think of training
right like
you need to have i'm not one for
schedule d loads
right so like just kind of speak more my
language like i will
train until i see indications that i
need to deload my training
and so that's why i see metrics as
something that's very important whether
it's
tracking heart rate variability whether
it's tracking bar speed or grip strength
or
velocity or whatever i need i need to
have data to tell me to slow down
otherwise i'm just going to keep going
and i think as you should right because
i think a lot of times if you
if you just succumb to these these
uh arbitrary regressions of intensity
you're actually going to be missing your
potential long term so i see that in
training and i've seen the benefit of
like okay
i see indicators that fatigue is now a
detriment to the progress in training
i am going to do something to offset
this fatigue and be able to perform
better
then that's when a period of d training
would ensue
rather than just oh i've been training
hard for three weeks i'm gonna cut my
volume back thirty percent cut my
intensity back thirty percent like man
what if that was the exact
point in which you should have showed up
and you should have turned up
so in business it's really similar where
it's like you know i can sit on my
laptop for days on end and not blink
but if i start to notice at the end of a
week i'm yielding less and i'm seeing
less progress
and i have these indicators that would
suggest to me that okay i need to
um i need to slow down and in order to
actually go forward
um so that for me is just having good
data
good metrics to track productivity
whether
that's number of words i type in a day
versus number of words i type in a week
um you know and tracking and setting
deadlines and creating urgency
so for me it's really just been a
process like okay
i'm at a point now where the metrics are
telling me that
in order to move forward i need to slow
down
uh and slow down strategically like i'm
not just going to f off and
you know just do some morning meditation
crap it's like no like i'm going to
still get up and work and work
efficiently and expediently but at the
end of
you know let's say once i get this one
project when i finish writing the book
then i'm going to take 10 days and i'm
out right so i kind of have like a
little bit of a push a little bit of a
pull
push to get the work done and then at
the end of it i get a bit of a reward
and i get to kind of de-load a bit after
that well once i've kind of
you know gone through similar to a
competition it's like okay
if i pull a pr at a meet i'm going to
take
you know a week or two off the back end
before i'm you know back really on the
barbell it's the same thing with this
it's like before i really
if in order for me to really sink my
teeth
into the next project i know i can't
just go from a max effort
getting this book through publication
get it through edit get it to print and
get it through distribution
to then turn around and i'm not going to
be 100 to the project i had planned out
for that
so that's going to be like all right
time to time to take off shut down and
then come back and
and start to plan again so it's not it's
not easy for me
like i've always always because i've
gotten whatever this is for our
abilities i don't know
what do we do like what is this this is
work for us somehow we've we've hacked a
system
that it takes it's a glitch in the
matrix man it is yeah
because i'm wearing sweatpants and i'm
technically employed like this is not
okay
but like because i've gotten here by
just pure grunt work
like sure oh how do you do this well if
you go on a plane and you travel around
the world for three years and you live
out of a suitcase and you trash every
relationship you've ever had
and you just say yes to every
opportunity you'll be able to do this so
i was like yeah great done that
now it's like okay how do i get to the
next level it's like well now you need
to
slow down you're like i don't know what
that means so it is difficult to have
the discipline now to
just like in training like you know
there are times when i train four days a
week
and that drives me nuts because it's
three days of me week to me climbing the
[ __ ] walls
but it's like i know that if i want to
get bigger if i want to get stronger i
have to only train four days a week in
this period
so i'm at the point now where it's like
all right from like a lifestyle
perspective
to overcome this plateau i need to
express the discipline enough to remove
myself from that attitude of like just
keep your head down don't blink take a
bunch of drugs and then just work until
you can't work anymore then work some
more
um so that's that's something that's
frankly taken more wrestling with
mentally than anything else i've ever
done because
you're telling me to not do something
but it's recognizing that that's what it
takes to get what you want and get to
where you need to be or where you want
to be if that makes sense
yeah it's a lot more nuanced right it's
very easy to just say
go all out that you know for all that
i'm very very impressed with
powerlifters and what those athletes can
achieve
it's not very subtle sport it's applied
the maximum amount of power
through the bar at all times
when you're on the competition floor
that's it you know and that i think
perhaps ports across onto the way that
people
sometimes think that they should live
their lives like what absolutist
creatures you know if i put a packet of
biscuits in front of you
and i say you can eat none of them or
you can eat all of them
both of those things are quite easy but
if you're only allowed to eat one
biscuit
it's [ __ ] torture they're like no no
i i can't do them i can't do the middle
i'm not good with moderation
i'm like i'm either no carbs or all
carbs
that's the way that we seem to be able
to do things because it removes the
decision
uh the requirement for decision removes
the requirement for subtlety
to me there's no such thing as
dedication in moderation
that doesn't make sense to me like how
can those two things coke how can you be
dedicated to something and still be
moderate and still be balanced
so like this is more of an approach of
like extreme balance
where it's like i will work as hard as i
can for as long as it sounds like a
semantic
game that you've played to sort of
repurpose this into your particular uh
your particular sort of cognitive makeup
yeah and it's these are the mental
gymnastics i have to play with myself to
get me to stop
just like burning the candle on both
ends um
but yeah like when i go to i don't know
i've i'm trying to find covered
free quarantine destinations that at the
end of february i can just leave to so
wherever that place is
that i go when i'm finished like the
book for example
there will be a period i don't know how
brief it'll be but there will be a day
or two where i don't open my laptop
i'm sure um i'm probably not going to go
the whole 10 days that i have allotted
without doing it but
i will i will deload my brain until what
degree i feel it's necessary and then
right back into the fire again
croatia dubai bali three
relatively open places brilliant i'll go
to all three
perfect what's the book about finish up
tell us about the book
yeah so the book is something that i've
been writing in accordance with kind of
our flagship course so i've
developed a handful of courses for some
gym franchises uh kind of all over so
brits would be familiar with ultimate
performance uh and canadians would be
familiar with good life fitness so i was
contracted
um many years ago to revamp the personal
training education
um in in both of those companies and
from there
sort of garnered a lot of interest in
social media to
be sort of taught similar principles
that i was teaching there obviously in a
private setting
so i kind of create it created this like
four month 16 week
course that i think would be okay if i
were to be a personal trainer starting
out
synthesizing my 15 years of as a
chiropractor
strength conditioning coach and a
personal trainer um and a strength
athlete to various various degree what
do i think is essential for people
to know from like anatomy and applied
biomechanics standpoint
so the book is essentially a manual for
that course
um so it's about the better part of 50
60 000 words now we're seeing across the
line
in the design stage and all that stuff
and editing
but yeah so it is a compliment to go
with the prescript level one curriculum
that basically is going to act as an
expanded version of the course and the
reference text
for that the for that particular course
and
yeah it's been somewhat of a the book it
predates the actual development of the
course itself so
this has been probably through four or
five years in the making now so
excited to get it across the line that's
cool when's it out
end of march so i said it now it has to
be true so yeah end of march should be
um when the next semester
goes live the students for next semester
will have access to purchase the hard
copy of the book
and then all previous coaches who have
gone through the course in the last
couple of years will have access to it
as well
that is a unique approach i haven't seen
from the outside looking in i'm aware
that i'm a total noob with this
i haven't really seen the training for
pt's at least in the uk
really seemed to take much development
and you see the sort of top-end
strength and conditioning stuff has
really changed but the entry level for
someone to be able to step out onto the
gym floor
it's just get you level three i think
it's pt level three in the uk
and you you walk into any crossfit gym
and
even the new coaches no more than that
even the people that are just
practicing for the level one and then i
imagine that you can take that one step
further and one step further and one
step further
yeah i think just given the current
landscape man like there's
there's no room in the market now
for mediocrity i think personal training
now is really going to return
back to a luxury item which it was 20
years ago right only
like only the rich and famous had
personal trainers 25 years ago
because it was it was deemed a luxury
not that i think they had an amazing
skill set then but i think
now that the consumer is getting smarter
the access of information
uh the barriers to that information are
less and less at the consumer level
you're really going to have to bring a
supreme
product as a trainer to the table if you
want to continue to do that as a career
or before it was like
i always i always compare personal
training akin to stripping
i know plenty of people that just
personal trained their way through
undergrad just like i know plenty of
people who just strip their way through
underground
it's like that market is not going to be
there anymore
um you know with commercial gym
franchises taking a hit
with you know people's budgets not
necessarily calling for them
and to you know have this disposable
income for
you know a luxury service like that and
people's like unwillingness to return
back into
into public facilities and open gym
spaces
i think there's really going to be a
high ticket
value placed on someone like look i'm
going to jump through all of these hoops
to be in person and take an hour of my
time and have a personal trainer
this person better be able to you know
drastically improve my quality of life
across many indices right so not only is
it just body composition and
transformation
but it is going to be pain and
performance as well so i think
there is going to be somewhat of an
enlightenment in the personal training
field
and raising the standard of just the
barrier of entry to people into that
field is definitely something that we're
kind of committed to
with the education that we put out so
we're not in the interest of dumbing
things down
we ask our coaches to sort of smarten up
and then collectively i think we're
hopefully starting to raise
the industry standard as a consequence
of that i hope so man uh
i do fear for pts that haven't decided
to do their cpd and take that
really seriously because you're not just
competing with other pts now
you're competing with crossfit classes
and bjj classes and yoga classes and
peloton
and zoom workouts and all this sort of
stuff so as the
leverage and the scalability of that has
increased
the level that you need to be at in
order to be able to compete with that as
a pt i think
is correct and that's a message i've
been saying for ages to every pt that i
know i'm like dude you need to
be [ __ ] hot with your branding you need
to be you need to understand how to
market you need to understand how to
retain clients your pricing strategy
needs to be clever you need to
understand how to do a schedule
you also need to make sure that your
actual knowledge of what you're doing
hasn't stagnated from when you first
became a pt
seven years ago shit's changed there's
new new studies being released every
single week
and i think especially because a lot of
pts get busy right
like especially when you've become well
known and you've got a name for yourself
pts can become really really busy my
old housemate lou was doing like 50
hours a week
of one to ones there's a [ __ ] ton of
one-to-ones
now he used to take he used to take time
off and he was like
deep deep into loving fitness so he was
always reading something he'd be reading
some magazine in between his
sessions and stuff i was thinking man
like 50 hours a week of one to one must
be
absolutely [ __ ] exhausting so yeah
it's uh
it's good man i hope i hope that that
does make people turn a corner
in the pt world i really think i really
hope yeah and you know we're not the
only ones out there doing it i think
there's a lot of really good educators
that are
that are attempting to raise the
standards so i think there's
because there's a market now for
decentralized education
um there's now a vetting process of
educators and who's really willing
or who's really willing to bring a
product to market that
is not just you know furthering the
noise and
you know entering more into the
repository of useless knowledge
that you know you can can you leave an
hour zoom call or an hour
lab session or an hour lecture and that
immediately affect the way you train the
next day so that's really kind of
where we're pushing uh where we're
pushing the education
is for immediate application obviously
with the limitations and hands-on
um you know we're gonna we're getting a
little bit uh you know
more clever with the way we're
delivering courses and interacting with
our students so
they can have that dramatic effect they
can get the return on the investment
immediately
and we're not just floating ideas in
their head for them to write clever
captions on instagram
yeah i hope so man people want to check
out what you do or
more about yourself where should they go
uh yeah so instagram's probably the best
way to find
me just to go on the internet so it's at
the underscore muscle underscore doc
a little bit of a deeper dive we find
you in our podcast
which is rx radio our xd radio
spotify itunes and all that stuff uh and
then
if you're interested in the education
side of things
that would be www.pre-dashscript.com
so that's where we run all our all our
education through so we have four
courses at the moment and that library
will be expanding to
seven by the time we hit 2022. so
instead we were working into 2022. i
wasn't lying
seven plus a book by the end of march uh
it will be five plus a book and then the
end of the year will be
seven plus three books and then the end
of 2022 into 2023 will be seven and
seven bucks
busy year ahead yes jordan man thank you
for your time
pleasure man thanks so much for uh
putting up with the technical
difficulties and all that and i
hopefully that hopefully the quality of
the production marks the quality of the
conversation
beautiful man hd bid